i'm soaking up this summer sun we have
all missed it so much
and i get to be poolside with our very
own celebrity dermatologist dr guanche
thanks for joining me
thank you lauren i'm so excited to be
here and to be
in person with you right now it is so
wonderful and i want to get all the tips
from you on how to achieve my best
summer skin
because i want to get out there and have
that good hot babe summer
well of course in addition to sunscreen
i recommend that you seek cover
like this beautiful cabana we're in
right now perfect or
a hat a great hat that blocks out uv
look for an spf
hat with a tight weave and
if you're really concerned about
wrinkles and sun damage you could wear
something like this
oh dr kwan chick with props today
want more self-care tips we teamed up
with dr guanche and rock skin care for
ways to keep your skin
hydrated and youthful you know i need
the secrets from you dr guanche so
what's a product that you love that i
can go get
my favorite is rox retinol correction
max hydration cream
maximum this product works i love it
it can deliver 24-hour hydration to your
face and neck
and in a clinical study on 32 women 97
had visibly reduced wrinkles in one week
is this a product that's going to break
the bank for me
not at all it's available at target for
under 25
okay after the pool we're hitting up
target
[Music]